[Musique]
bienvenue dans ce nouveau numéro de paf
nous allons commenter une actualité
assez grave d'ailleurs avec anne
charlène bezina bonjour bonjour patrice
voit bien tout va dire avec stéphane bon
sens alors j'ai oublié de préciser que
vous enseignez le bras droit public
notamment et la science politique mais
c'était important de tuer tout allait
bien aussi mais tout va bien quand même
c'est ça et à côté vous stéphane vincent
qui était doyen de la faculté de droit
de versailles saint quentin en scène
toujours exactement professeur fonction
dangereuse fonction thierry aux va voir
parce qu'il ya des doyens voilà qui sont
obligés de démissionner et rien qui
tourne mal
est-ce qu'il vous est arrivé d'aller jeu
cagoule et non avec mes genoux mais je
vous raconte rien à petit ça s'est passé
à montpellier lanthier mais ça fait
plaisir de voir des profs de droit qui
sont pour garde à vue des soutiens dans
sa présidente de la république elle ne
sont pas non plus éditeur alors
évidemment la semaine a été
marqué par ce qui s'est passé dans
l'aude et par l'hommage national au
lieutenant colonel beltrame qui a eu
lieu il ya quelques jours avec un
discours
du président de la république d'emmanuel
mâcon un discours quand vous avez vous
trouvé d'ailleurs ces dix couples tout
beau plutôt émouvant plutôt bien un beau
discours pendant la fin on en attendait
pas moins de mode de macron qui prend
bien l'ailé des habits costume de chef
de l'état de chef des armées il a dit à
peu près ce qui fait ce qu'on ne
s'attendait à ce qu'ils puissent
exprimer qui discourt sur la partie sur
la jeunesse et la plus importante vers
la fin du discours après c'est tout le
problème mais c'est pas le problème de
macron c'est que encore une fois c'est
un beau discours puis voilà ça va pas
changer grand chose sinon c'était une
très belle cérémonie très émouvante une
certaine unité
donc c'est très bien et puis même macro
et fait parfaitement le job ça c'est
bien mais voilà après et alors ce que
j'ai envie de dire alors après là
peut-être sur deux sur la cérémonie elle
même
cet événement sans le la cérémonie je
les regardais alors pas en direct mais
en différé gelé je trouve que le
président de république était dans son
rôle afin que manuel macron était bien
dans le rôle du président de république
de ce qu'on peut en attendre sous la
vème république en tout cas ils contenu
de son discours moi je les ai trouvés
sur 10 courses très juste j'ai pour moi
le plus important la wii la partie sur
la jeunesse j'ai trouvé cela assez
efficaces en termes encore une fois de
discours et j'ai aussi quand même noter
l'inscription la volonté d'inscrire ce
dans l'excellent situation dans
l'histoire est dans ce que l'on pourrait
cavale et le rhin cette pâte et des oies
d'unîmes de verdun et des justes et les
compagnons de jade et ce qui est fait
pour vous c'est un email alors des
histoires qui sont très lointaine les
unes des autres même église
c'est ce qu'on appelle l'esprit de
résistance dans ces zones oui moi c'est
aussi la partie du discours que j'ai que
j'ai aimé cette inscription dans cette
idée de la résistance et dans dans le
goût de la liberté qu'on a finalement en
france il a plusieurs fois rappelé
justement notre le fait que la france
est attaquée notamment par rapport à ses
valeurs par rapport à ce caractère que
nous avons et je trouve pour le coup que
ce discours est aussi important pour
lancer la suite justement peut-être la
concrétisation juridique de de ce qu'il
faudra faire face au terrorisme
c'est ça qui était important aussi c'est
qu'à la fois c'était un disco que je
trouvais assez en phase de ces réalités
qui a osé qualifier les choses et
c'était c'était un moment important et
vous avez raison de souligner c'est vrai
qu'il ya comme ça des moments alors
c'est un moment grave et triste
enfin c'est aussi un moment d'unanimité
qui n'a pas duré longtemps qui a pas
duré cependant on va aborder après le
nous fonde le fond des choses c'est à
dire la prévention du terrorisme la même
mais là ce qui me paraît quand même très
très important c'est cette découverte de
cet héroïsme cet acte héroïque de ce
héros absolu et donc effectivement tout
le monde ça me semble avoir besoin c'est
vrai qu'on en a besoin de héros
une belle image un type jeune type
brillant un type qui change sa place
contre une comme contre une otage alors
qu'on lui demande pas ce que mon
président m'a kron a dit il à 10000 plus
beaucoup de braves ne l'aurait peut-être
pas fait pourtant des gens très brave
c'est vrai que nous tous autour de la
table
est-ce qu'on aurait été capable de dire
mais finalement non vous allez je vais
me substituer à la ses ventes fortement
skd meilleur sprinter luc ferry qui
finissait dans un livre il avait raison
c'est vrai que aujourd'hui contrairement
à vous y passez en 1914 plus grand monde
qui dirait je vais donner ma vie pour la
pour la nation exactement je vais aller
mourir pour voilà pour la pour la france
ce pour qu'on est prêt pour se battre
dit il c'est pour ses proches peut-être
pour sa famille mais ça dépasse pas çà
et là
peut-être qu'on renoue justement avec
donné sa vie pour la france c'est ça et
c'est quelque chose qui n'existait pas
depuis qu'il ne peut pas exister dont
les circonstances
heureusement peut-être n'existait pas
depuis longtemps c'est absolument
extraordinaire et et ce à une traduction
directe parce que la gendarmerie depuis
cette journée funeste reçois je crois
plus de 40 ou 50 téléphone par jour
deux jeunes qui veulent s'engager dans
la gendarmerie qui se disent vas y à
l'image de du colonel bertrand
voilà c'est c'est ce qui nous fait c'est
ce que nous fait rêver c'est un bel
exemple
donc voilà ça réveille quelque chose
effectivement comme vous le dit très
justement de cette idée de mourir pour
la patrie s'est substitué au fait deux
ans et que ça n'existait plus voilà on
était tous un peu individualiste on dit
maintenant et moi ça me concerne pas en
nous on voit bien quelquefois dans les
métro puis on en parlera tout à l'heure
même l'attitude des vigiles à
montpellier qui y voit des gens et après
c'est une différence énorme entre deux
comportements contraires que et là je
viens temps qu'on ait basculé avec avec
cet officier
cet acte héroïque vraiment héroïque il
ya une symétrie aussi kyi qui a été
souligné c'est à dire que dans les
saisies pouvant table personnes qui sont
en face on leur martyr leur héros et
absolue il est indispensable que nous
aussi nous fabriquions entre guillemets
nos héros que nous reconnaissions nos
héros et puis il y avait un second
élément aussi que moi qui me marquent
souvent dans les discours de du
président de la république et qui me
marquer alors qu'il était encore
candidat c'est la paix la jeanne d'arc
qui revient nationale il était en
quelque sorte expropriés du champ de
propriété dans la dans lequel elle se
trouvait jusqu'à présent c'est-à-dire le
champ du front national d'extrême droite
qui avait fait de jeanne d'arc
son héroïne voilà que jeanne d'arc
revient dans le giron national dans un
grand récit qui va de jeanne d'arc à de
gaulle et je trouve que c'est très
habile et que ses traits tout à fait
légitime que jeanne d'arc n'est pas la
propriété de l'extrême droite galette
une qu'elle est aussi une héroïne
nationale fabre il est tout ce qui nous
allume a présidé à orléans alors qu'il
était encore dennis je crois où j'étais
ministre
en tout cas président les ai faites
jeanne d'arc c'est passionnant parce que
si on regarde au fond comment elle était
récupérée elle était absolument
récupérer par tout le monde
ça a était la fille du peuple récupéré
par la gauche ça a été ensuite l'église
catholique set et s'est sentie
catholique
ça a été ça a été la république ça et et
l'extrême droite et maintenant c'est
vrai qu'elle revienne la canonisation de
jeanne d'arc est un cadeau du saint
siège
on est jaloux j'arrive 1924 le vatican
offre sainte jeanne d'arc à la france en
échange d'une attitude juridiquement
d'ailleurs plus compréhensive de la
france à l'égard des associations
cultuelles catholique
donc c'est la fin jeanne d'arc delà de
la guerre issue entre guillemets de la
guerre issue de la loi du 9 décembre
mais est-ce qu'elle aussi était parfois
des volumes en transit anti-religieuse
presque enfin donc anti religieuse
antilles anglaises et anti allemande
même du tout laurier cet hommage
national youth des hommages un petit peu
partout en france je vous propose
d'écouter jean luc courcoult qui le
maire de montigny qui a rendu aussi
hommage au lieutenant colonel beltrame
je pense que la démarche que ce colonel
a fait en sacrifiant sa vie pour sauver
celle de quelqu'un d'autre est tout à
fait exceptionnel dans l'histoire de
france et un moment donné nous en tant
qu'élu mais également tous les
représentants de la population de
montigny nous avons souhaité
faire cet hommage non seulement c'est
important mais c'est même indispensable
cette barbarie de l'islamisme c'est en
étant tous unis tous vraiment solidaire
on arrivera je ne dis pas à l'éradiquer
mais au moins à la combattre il faut
vraiment que nous soyons fermes sur les
valeurs qui sont celles de la france et
que nous nous battions tous et c'est
l'action de nous tous au quotidien qui
permettra je dirais de passer les
passages veut dire pendant pendant qu'on
écoutait le maire de montigny c'est vrai
que ça redore aussi l'image ou dans le
temps le nom de l'opinion des forces de
sécurité elle c'est vrai que je trouve
que pendant la période de l'état
d'urgence il ya eu une période un petit
peu contrarié de la confiance qu'on
pouvait faire à nos forces de sécurité
et de police et notamment en voyant cet
acte là vous le disiez ça prouve aussi
que ce sont des personnels qui sont des
cibles privilégiées malheureusement de
ces attaques terroristes et et qui donc
sont capables de mourir pour la france
et ça je crois qu'on oubliait un petit
peu ces dernières années malheureusement
alors pourtant que la menace n'a jamais
été aussi élevé et ce a rétabli un petit
peu les choses dans leurs dons leur
réalité quotidienne finalement et c'est
vrai alors très difficile alors il ya
des moments comme ça dit on sait pas si
dur extrêmement longtemps parce qu'il y
avait la chanson de renaud jean passer
un flic c'était le président du sénat
qui avait voulu citer le type de leurs
chances aux grandes et des gens votent
c'est un flic il est il enfin ils
connaissent pas bien la chanson gaie
comme robin c'est un flic sur la bouche
du président
non mais voilà c'est vraiment je trouve
que le sentiment national est assez bien
révélé par nos forces de police et de
sécurité qui finalement prennent les
premières balles sont sont avant tout là
pour nous protéger et c'est même ce
principe des forces de sécurité des
forces de l'ordre qui sont qui sont là
pour nous au quotidien et c'est bien que
des actes comme ça rappelle finalement
leur rôle dans la république alors
unanimité dans l'hommage
il n'y a pas forcément une limite et
dans la politique à suivre contre le
terrorisme notamment anthony laurent
wauquiez dénoncé l'irresponsabilité la
naïveté ou la légèreté du président de
la république et de son gouvernement
est ce que est ce que là aussi alors
dans cette lutte qui probablement
compliquer on va en parler mais est ce
que est ce que c'est ça doit être un
sujet de querelle politique ou est ce
qu'il faudrait plutôt chercher un accord
une unanimité en faire leur nid ça me
choque pas c'est un peu le boulot de
l'opposition de secouer le cocotier
parce que c'est vrai que là même si
personne va tout le monde a été au
pouvoir personne n'a bien sûr oui mais
on ne peut pas non plus être là juste
spectateurs de 7
barbarie on dit en bon bah oui oui c'est
terrible oui alors on fait des beaux
discours de tous les experts viennent
s'épanche on dénombre on c'est n'importe
quel français sait exactement combien de
fichiers est ce qu est la vison ça on
connaît ou koné mais maintenant le
nouveau fichier la fpt r je sais plus
quoi donc on devient tous experts en
fichage de futurs terroristes
mais voilà et après qu'est ce qu'on fait
donc je comprends que des hommes
politiques et à coeur mais voilà quelle
est la prochaine étape et on peut pas
juste te dire voquer l'onf et d'unité
nationale multinationales qua non c'est
ça suffit pas visiblement moi je ne
reproche rien au prénom a grandi à
edouard philippe may mais voilà je peux
comprendre qu'on ait envie que les
choses changent heures moi je trouve que
par exemple manuel valls quand il dit il
faut interdire le salafisme je suis pas
expert c'est peut-être d'abord on voit
pas trop comment comment faire une chose
pareille mais au moins les choses sont
dites il ya quelqu'un qui exprime une
idée qui est née voilà on sait que les
salafistes sont pas tout à fait en phase
avec nos valeurs arrêtons stoppons
stopper tout ça au moins le mérite de
lancer le débat c'est bien c'est bien
aussi quand il dit mais c'est pas on
peut pas toujours se réfugier en disant
c'est le chômage c'est l'économie j'ai
heureusement que tous les gens qui sont
malheureux professionnellement et
malheureux socialement deviendra
terroristes donc c'est vrai c'est vrai
que ce cette façon de voir qu'un en ce
moment le gouvernement de ses ira mieux
quand tout ira mieux ben oui oui mais
enfin on n'est pas chez les bisounours
non heureusement on peut être pauvre
malheureux et ne pas devenir terroriste
voilà mais vous pensez bien qu'un cadre
des responsabilité de la naïveté non
c'est pas la naïveté c'est que ces taux
se reprend les mots de wim et laurent
wauquiez il est un peu dans son rôle il
exagère sûrement sais pas si c'est pas
de la naïveté c'est d'abord que tous les
transferts sans désagrément un peu non
mais quand on est tout à fait on attend
en
on a un peu plus les mâles y est c'est
très compliqué pour des décisions nous
avons les enregistrements des émissions
précédentes ne changèrent l'on pourrait
faire comme ça une une petite
chronologie de votre discours sur
laurent wauquiez je pensais qu'il
exagère un peu
moi j'ai une fille béat devant personne
donc voilà je peux reconnaître des
choses bonnes et mauvaises c'est tout un
social ne m'attendais pas de vous je moi
j'ajouterais il ya à mon avis à deux
choses assez paradoxal dans finalement
cette lutte contre le terrorisme c'est
que c'est normal je suis d'accord avec
toi que ce soit une question politique
de premier plan notamment parce que
malheureusement c'est le sait notre
actualité donc n'importe quel acteur
politique est obligé de se saisir d'un
sujet qui concerne tous les français
aussi docile d'aussi près néanmoins moi
je trouve que la deuxième phase de la
pièce qu'on exploite un peu moins c'est
que précisément je ne suis pas sûr que
politiquement signé des réponses de
droite de gauche du milieu d'extrême
droite d'extrême gauche à ces questions
et que tout soit juridiquement
exploitable en plus donc à mon sens il
est peut-être quand même important qu'on
puisse tous dire que évidemment même
nous en tant que citoyen on essaye de
lutter contre les manifestations de ce
terrorisme et il est difficile de
trouver les bons outils et peut-être
qu'on a besoin plus sur ce sujet là que
sur d'autres d'unité nationale et je
crois c'est peut-être un peu dommage
justement que l'opposition prennent son
rôle d' exagération comme comme tu veux
comme tu dis c'est vrai que ça fait
partie du jeu politique en général mais
sur ces sujets là est ce qu'on n'a pas
besoin aussi de se sentir tous dans le
même bateau tous français tous en phase
avec une même lutte et finalement amené
un même ennemi commun qui est l'ami
commun aussi bien pour ce qu'on va dire
sur l'antisémitisme que sur l'ailé et
peut-être même les violences à
montpellier en tout cas on a tous ce
même ennemi qu'est la violence qu'elle à
kehl à la manifestation d'opposition de
groupuscules comme ça et donc moi je
trouve qu'on devrait avoir plus d'unités
sur ce type de question de bon sens au
delà des aboiements
ces machins enfin mon jeu rien ne lui
fait peur et c'est à cela qu'on leur
connaît il ya ce 10ème charlene est très
juste c'est à dire que il ya aussi une
éthique de responsabilité quand on se
veut se proclamer chef de l'opposition
qui est d'ailleurs un concept qui n'est
pas qui n'est pas français
enfin qu'il n'existe pas en france il ya
de l'énoncé dénoncer c'est bien mais
ensuite c'était votre question jean
charles comme disait bourvil le dire
c'est bien mais le faire c'est mieux
donc
remettons mettons en quand les 18 gilles
fichait totalement irresponsable et
lorsque moi en tant que citoyen
j'entends ce discours j'ai l'impression
d'être franchement la désagréable
impression d'être pris pour un crétin
oui c'est ça est ce qu est ce que c est
responsable voilà de dire ça parce que
en réalité on voit bien quand il ya des
attaques connues dans ce supermarché ça
peut on voit bien que les français
voient bien que ça peut se produire
n'importe quand n'importe où et quand
ding entre guillemets on n'est jamais à
l'abri de ses actes enfin on peut aussi
comprendre la légitime indignation des
français à chaque fois qu'un acte
terroriste oui un machin il at elle agi
les fichiers s depuis tant de temps il
habitait la laddh
on a été convoqué comme un parent
d'élève gaccio il était là on le suivait
mais là alors là en plus lasse et cerise
sur le gâteau ce type là et on allait
alléger sa surveillance en plus donc
c'est là on est quand même et ça c'est
un problème de renseignements c'est pas
un problème politique c'est quand même
le politique qui qui j'ai un peu il ya
de la concurrence mais en tout cas je
comprends l'incompréhension des défenses
et en os mais ok alors ils sont les sont
fichés s on peut rien faire pour
l'instant ils vont agir et on sera été
fiché s est donc on pourra voir la photo
du type tout de suite et puis son
adresse c'est sympa mais je pense que
les gens du super u doivent apprécier
moi derrière cette façon de faire c'est
donc on peut comprendre que c'est vrai
qu'il ya des réactions
il ya un dysfonctionnement de ce
dysfonctionnement de ce fichier s de ce
qu'on appelle ces fichiers est d'abord
on sait pas très bien quinze mille vingt
mille
enfin le nombre de gens qui sont floues
même temps il faut pas non plus tout
noircir c'est c'est aussi grâce à ce
fichier que je crois ou deux attentats
qui sont des jouets parc d'attractions
côté extraordinaire dans la lutte contre
le terrorisme et qui fonctionne mais
c'est vrai qu'il faut peut-être mieux
expliquer comment ça se passe pour que
du coup les français comprennent ont
évoqué il ya des fichiers est on ne peut
pas suivre 18000 personnes mais on en
arrête souvent on
ou parme plus pressé on a évité des
catastrophes dire à quel moment de 500
sites et le lieu mais voilà on a hélas
il ya une mauvaise communication
peut-être qui fait qu on comprendrait
mieux ce qui se passe là on a juste
l'impression que on les ressent sont les
comptabilise on les connaît et puis
c'est tout alors que c'est bien
évidemment pas ça moi j'ajouterai un
petit élément c'est que nous nous les
français sommes très ambivalent sur
plein de points
on nous reproche finalement reproche à
nos services de sécurité de connaître
les attaquants et puis finalement après
on our on reproche aussi ses services de
sécurité de ne pas connaître des gens
comme dardel le landais par exemple
qu'on découvre comme étant finalement
peut-être quelqu'un qui a un fichier
plus gros que lui
et là pour le coup l'opinion est
également révolté du fait que les
services soient surpris
donc est ce qu'il vaut mieux qu'on sache
ce qui va nous arriver ou est ce qu'il
vaut mieux qu'on soit surpris l'opinion
et jamais plus ou moins en accord parce
que de toute façon elle est très choquée
face à ce type d'actes donc c'est
simplement c'est pour ça que je j'ai
tendance à me méfier aussi des données
sur l'émotionnel
voilà des statistiques qui sont publiés
par tous les journaux aujourd'hui hier
sur ces question de savoir si les
français sont favorables à des camps de
rétention ou et ses prises à chaud
évidemment on est tous très choqués
saint lizier musical quand vous dis
voilà j'ai deux mesures que je prends
qui est facile et il y aura plus
d'attentats pas de raison c'est vraiment
à vis de droite de gauche du milieu
d'accord c'était plus difficile que sa
simple et plus subtil plus lte est un
peu plus complexe et oserais-je le thème
la pensée complexe du président de la
république a été raillé ce n'était
peut-être pas très adroit d'ailleurs de
l'évoquer mais les choses sont
compliquées et ce type de entre
guillemets parce qu'il faut y mettre des
guillemets de guerre contre le
terrorisme est une jeune entreprise de
très longue haleine et ne se règle pas à
coude aboiements maladroit l'opposition
est dans son rôle mais elle serait
encore plus dans son rôle si elle le
réfléchissez en effet jugé l'accord et
charlène peut-être de manière peut-être
plus consensuel mettons les
intelligences ensemble et l art est
toujours plus intelligent à plusieurs
ensemble et puis il faut faire attention
aussi à la désinformation que cette
opposition systématique peut créer on le
sait en tant que juriste finalement on
entend beaucoup de choses sur la guerre
que nous sommes en train de vivre
rappelons le on n'est vraiment pas en
état de guerre et puis au delà de ça
voilà juridiquement à peu près tout ce
qui a été avancé par laurent wauquiez
dans dans son tweet ou dans ses propos
récents mais tape son nom alors c'est ça
dans les duels il ya nous en parlions
avec anne charlène tout à l'heure un
appel alors non pas jeanne d'arc mais
j'entendais l'un des responsables de des
républicains il y a peu qui invoquait le
notre collègue bertrand mathieu qui est
professeur a pas rien et qui dans le
figaro vox ou je ne sais quel site a
produit un article selon lequel il
serait juridiquement possible d'internés
tous les fichiers sd fichier s certes
alors je suis allé lire cette ce petit
billet il n'est pas un article au
demeurant mais ce que le responsable des
républicains omettait de préciser c'est
que notre collègue mathieu prenait pour
hypothèse que nous étions en état de
guerre charlene a raison de souligner
nous ne sommes pas juridiquement on
était là mais c'est vrai que c'est
on n'arrête pas de répéter c'est la
guerre on est en guerre
et c'est juridiquement on ne l'est pas
peut-être alors est-ce que j'ai pas lu
par le biais mais il y avait une
hypothèse qui était possible qui est
dire mal puisqu'on est en guerre
puisqu'ils nous ont déclaré la guerre
déclarant leur la guerre et puis là on
applique la convention de genève je
crois et ont donc on peut interne et qui
ose creton oui mais je sais pas lorsqu
on sait les chiens de regarder les faits
totalement jeudi on peut retomber dans
gotham hameau du bois oui bien sûr et je
crois qu'en plus il n'y a qu'un seul
état de guerre on est d'accord
conditionnellement cesser la pratique 36
il faut le déclarer qu'on est pas notre
parlement qui se réunissent et ils font
un ennemi et voilà or c'est le problème
du terrorisme c'est que c'est un an et
demi avant tout une idéologie diffus qui
n'est pas localisable
parce que sans cela je pense que
d'ailleurs la france n'est pas la seule
à être touchée il faut le rappeler
donc du coup ce serait sûrement un
conflit mondial on serait peut-être
alors dans dans un conflit qui aurait
une tout autre ampleur donc je ne crois
pas qu'on puisse utiliser le mot guerre
en tout cas juridiquement à tort et à
travers et là encore ça fait partie du
rôle responsable de l'opposition de ne
pas envoyer des béquilles qui à mon sens
mais si le dira que je veux dire manuel
valls dit vas y eut beaucoup de gens à
quiconque et employer le terme de guerre
voilà alors qui est un terme en effet
politique que juridique
curieux c'est que qu'on soit en guerre
ou pas l'ennemi c'est bien y vient en
les terroristes et à vous écouter depuis
dix minutes on a l'impression que à la
suite de cet acte odieux
l'ennemi ce serait évoquée mais on s'en
fout de vos pieds non mais je veux dire
que vous perdez tout de suite sens des
réalités l'a déjà collé pas vous en suis
voulu parler que vous ne parlez que de
lui de ce qu'il a dit de ce qui devrait
dire vous le traité d'abruti vous le bon
je veux dire ça annonce franchement non
ok abruti c'est à ça qu'on les reconnaît
non le pire c'est qu'ils les bleus
virent bon lorsqu'il tient ce genre de
mes propos le meilleur c'est qu'il est
ce que je veux dire c'est assez curieux
selon sana c'est assez curieux de se
focaliser sur sur sur wauquiez à l'heure
qu'il est non mais je veux dire de
qualité sur quelqu'un donc de faire le
maître et menace terroriste je sais pas
ça me paraît pas du tout le sujet jeudi
la question est qu'est ce qu'on peut
faire
arrêtons de parler de vous est ce que
dans ce qu'on peut faire croire à
l'opinion parce que l'opinion est
sensible à ça est-ce qu'il ya parfois un
peu de démagogie ou très peu vrai mais
l'opic l'opinion et dans laquelle on
tente des choses surtout l oms l envie
que les gens s'exprimer et des idées
l'opinion ne peut pas se satisfaire et
la raison de discours lénifiants de
jean-louis on est triste oui c'est
terrible
oui eh ben voilà c'est en gros c'est ça
et je me retirerai sont pas se
satisfaire de la question de savoir
pourquoi nous parlons de laurent
wauquiez qui finalement ne nous obsède
pas la nuit je crois nous parle je parle
ont reçu aux enchères c'est la question
du rôle de l'opposition c'est finalement
c'est pour ça qu'on en parle et c est ce
que l'opposition doit écouter l'opinion
finalement dans ses fantasmes n'ai pu
peut-être aussi les plus j'ai envie de
vivre aussi
allez dans cette humanité qui parfois
peut se révolter contre la cruauté de
manière tout à fait j'ai envie de dire
intuitive instinctive
alors que finalement l'opposition est
aux manettes de quelque chose de
politique de juridique qui doit l'amener
à agir sur quelque chose de concret donc
j'ai peur que en écoutant alors la
veille de la peine de mort de
l'abolition de la peine de mort je crois
que le figaro avait titré qu'un sondage
disait qu'à 80%
le peuple était encore pourrait
finalement on a ensuite les années
ensuite dit que c'était magnifique
d'avoir pu faire évoluer les mentalités
grâce à la législation donc c'est cette
question qu'il faut poser c'est est-ce
qu'il faut écouter l'instinct qui nous
vient à tous de se dire il faut qu'on
lutte de manière unanime contre ces
cruautés ou est-ce qu'il faut essayer
peut-être plus ponctuellement d'arriver
à trouver des mesures utiles et juste
pour se battre contre un ennemi qui
finalement va nous poser à mon avis
beaucoup plus de problèmes qu une guerre
tels qu'on les appelait lui causera plus
de problèmes que wauquiez lui-même ces
frais là on attend une émission d'appels
rasure alors on attend quelques
décisions parce que pour l'instant on
pas grand chose venait en tout cas on
attend effectivement je crois que
président bakr on doit faire un discours
assez important peut-être sur le sujet
dans quelques temps parce que j'en vois
pas mais il faut qu'il faut qu'ils aient
comme l impression que les choses
peuvent éventuellement bouger tout en
expliquant qu' on pourrait dire
l'arsenal juridique il existe c'est vrai
il ya tout ce qu'il faut
est-ce que là encore est ce qu'on est
obligé de faire une loi chaque nouvelle
le feu martic et prier et cela de pas
depuis l'élection de macron mais bahamas
et euh
c'est de revenir sur ce que par dont
jean-charles sur ce que nicolas sarkozy
avait avait fait à savoir de recréer des
emplois dans les forces de l'ordre dans
les services de renseignement les
quelques entre guillemets experts que
j'ai pu lire ou entendre sur le sujet
convergent vers cette voie là c'est de
longue haleine
il faut recruter plus de gens encore
pour effectuer ces opérations qui sont
délicates c'est déjà une action mais sur
le long terme qui n'est peut-être pas si
spectaculaires que cela mais je jeu
apparemment c'est une action efficace
sûrement vers son retrait pour peut-être
pour terminer ce débat sur le propos de
laurent wauquiez que nous laisseront
tranquille ensuite c'est la question de
d'arrêter de confondre peut-être la
rétention et la détention
faisons un petit moment d'amphithéâtre
je crois c'est pas leur temps en disant
que précisément la rétention c'est de
l'administratif et du préventif c'est à
dire que on a des forces de des forces
de renseignement la dgsi qui dit je
crois qu'on peut le dire travaille
vraiment formidablement essaye de faire
tout leur possible pour prévenir ce qui
va se passer mais on est dans le domaine
de la prévention
donc on caractérise quelqu'un par
rapport à sa dangerosité éventuelle est
incriminé ou aujourd'hui penser à
retenir est donc à détenir des personnes
sur lesquelles nous n'avons que des fins
faisceau d'indicés par rapport à nos la
voilà de la prévention ça n'est
juridiquement pas possible étant donné
qu'à partir du moment où on est dans la
répression
on est rentré dans quelque chose qui
pénalement va devenir répréhensible et
pour lequel vous ne pouvez plus
bénéficier des garanties qui sont celles
lorsque vous n'avez rien commis donc
malheureusement vous allez me dire c'est
triste qu'on soit obligés d'attendre
qu'il y ait une réponse pénale quand
vous avez commis un crime mais comment
arriver à vous retenir avant que vous
ayez co
et quels sont les critères pour que
quelqu'un va devenir criminels on rentre
dans une série netflix finalement et on
n'est plus du tout dans un style
problème de deux non pas du fichier en
tant que tel mais deux peut-être de la
façon dont il est compris par l'opinion
parce qu'on sait pas très bien ce que
c'est que ces gens qui sont dans ce
fichier ss qui sont toutes
potentiellement des criminels en
puissance à ce que c'est le problème
c'est qu'on ne sait pas on sait pas très
bien moi j'en fin j'en ai discuté à
plusieurs reprises avec des des amis
dans là j'ai des amis dans la police
figurez vous les étuis embrassé sur la
bouche
non je me suis abstenu et bons les uns
et les autres me l'ont bien dit ce sont
en quelque sorte des civils et des andes
entre guillemets des actes de même pas
d'en quête des actes qui potentiellement
pourrait servir à entamer engagé une
enquête mais ce n'est rien de plus
il ya donc autour de ces fiches des
fantasmes à c'est vraiment très très
ancrée notamment dans l'opinion publique
ce ne sont pas des criminels qui sont
fichés ce sont des individus qui pour la
plupart ont la nationalité française
donc il va falloir que marine le pen
nous explique comment est-ce qu'on peut
les reconduire malades ou dans le cantal
ou en auvergne où je ne sais où
et d'autre part sont des joueurs qui
peuvent mais présent pour lequel non
mais je ne sais pas qu'est ce qu'on en
avait parlé à un moment d'aller
repeupler les villages d'auvergne avec
dépit de mettre des barbelés autour donc
enfin voilà il faut hélas cet outil là
ne permet pas à lui seul donne
règle un problème réglé le problème des
politiques qui permettraient de régler
un problème non mais mais pas par
exemple on peut on peut considérer quand
même à juste titre que quelquefois de
l'éviction de d'imams prônant le jihad
depuis des années on le fait mais c'est
difficile avec beaucoup de lenteur
alors c'est très bien de respecter
beaucoup de choses mais on peut
comprendre aussi que quand on apprend
qu'un type prêche depuis dix ans et que
là on va le mettre dehors n'est pas ok
c'est bien vaut mieux mettre 2 au bout
de 10 ans ou de 20 ans mais quand on met
au point de vue de l'opinion publique
encore une fois il n'y a pas besoin de
faire une nouvelle loi on aimerait que
de temps en temps
et là c'est un peu les données mesure
c'est un peu une volonté politique de
dire ok meur dont vous avez une agréable
et état de guerre sous jacents et
maintenant on rentre dans le dur on
n'accepte pas pas besoin d'attendre dix
ans de prêches valorisables mais le end
dernier chiffre que j'avais je pense
qu'il est aujourd'hui dépassée jeu
c'était 27 mais je crois que ça doit
être 30 32 ou 35 aujourd'hui fermeture
de deux cultes par l'autorité
administrative de la loi le permet je ne
dis pas que ce n'est pas fait je dis que
j'apprécierais que ce soit quelque fois
avec un peu plus de rapidité mais
peut-être terminons par l'étude de d'un
mot c'est le mot danger dangerosité qui
appellent finalement les fiches s les
fiches de renseignements on est tous en
train d'essayer de prévenir le danger
mais finalement ce critère là c'est
peut-être le critère le plus protéiforme
complice le connaître soi qu'est ce que
c'est le danger comment connaître un
individu dangereux parce que c'était le
même critère qui avait été avancée pour
la rétention de sûreté d'ailleurs dans
l'est dans la législation de 2008 et des
milliers de rapports d'études avait
essayé avec des psychiatres des juristes
de savoir quand on pouvait diagnostiqué
comme un individu comme dangereux parce
que c'est la même chose un terroriste
qu'un récidiviste c'est quelqu'un qui
peut commettre un acte dangereux pour la
société
et voilà pour peut-être que tout tout
tout le danger voyez ça m'est venu
et là c'est que je ne sais pas si on
peut prévenir ce qui nous arrive au
quotidien même ça ça le rêve de tout le
bon policier prévenir à d'autres
initiatives
la suspicion est fait est fait comme
intelligence artificielle confiance le
robot peut être artificiel nous et ça
avec un laurent wauquiez artificielle la
autres activités et autres actualités
pardon extrêmement dramatique c'est
l'assassinât de mme irié lou knoll
dix survivants taraf du vel d'hiv et
cette marche blanche qui a eu lieu avec
quand même j'avais dû ce type du monde
les violences contre les juifs ne cesse
d'augmenter en france et il ya en effet
un certain nombre de commentateurs et un
article dans le monde qui disait ce ne
sont plus les seuls lieux publics les
juifs doivent dorénavant éviter les
écoles publiques ont ils doivent retirer
leurs enfants
seul le poids de les menaces constantes
à les synagogues dans lesquelles ils ne
peuvent se rendre qu'au prix de mille
précautions c'est au sein même de leur
magasin et davantage encore de leur
appartement que la mort peut frapper
bien évidemment tout ça est horrible et
et mais on comprend assez vite comment
ça peut se passer quand on voit et c'est
pas moi qui le dit c'est les syndicats
d'enseignants des tonnes d'enseignants
et c'est là qu'il ya des endroits en
france où les angles et les profs ne
peuvent pas enseigner la shoah en classe
donc partant de là puisque on accepte
cet état de fait on accepte que dans des
classes et des sujets qu'on ne puisse
pas abordés il faut pas s'étonner de ce
qui arrive après des actes antisémites
se dire c'est la conséquence bien
logique donc là encore une fois n'a pas
besoin de faire de nouvelles lois il a
simplement de faire respecter
un état de fait républicain un programme
et puis voilà de prendre les décisions
qui s'imposent
maintenant on met un couvercle sur cette
chose cette chose là on veut pas en
parler parce que ça va être dans des
quartiers difficiles on est où là la
scission si on dit ça c'est moche mais
voilà mais il faut reconnaître ça et
tout s'explique on pourra faire des
millions et des millions de marche
blanche ça ne changera rien je voulais
dire c'est peut-être aussi qu'il ya deux
antisémitisme non on va il ya un
antisémitisme français classique l etat
et puis un antisémitisme plus récent est
probablement plus violents aujourd'hui
et que parfois la transition de deux
comptes du conflit israélo-palestinien
est ici pour enfin voir et des images d'
images terribles la fin de ce que
peuvent être les juifs dans l' affaire
halimi et c'est donc partant glace est
un qui est en effet peut-être que c'est
ça qu'on a eu du mal à appréhender un
nouvel antisémitisme par rapport à
l'antisémitisme classique que con qu'on
a connu et qui a donné en effet la shoah
23 et j'ai pas entendu le veut beaucoup
de 10 d une solution pour dire ben voilà
il faut lui il faut effectivement qu'on
puisse enseigner l'histoire à nos
enfants partout alors il ya bien
évidemment des tonnes de classe on peut
l'apprendre mais il ya aussi pas mal de
classes qu'on peut pas et c'est le vrai
parce que l'entraînement c'est pas une
conséquence plutôt que d'ordonner
d'autres fins
la cause si on classe vous pouvez pas
dire ce qui s'est passé contre les juifs
ça veut dire belge
donc est-ce que c'est pas la conséquence
d'un antisémitisme plutôt que la cause
de ces bricolages
on retrouve dans ce que tu dis
jean-charles finalement une forme de
résultat d'un long glissement qui date à
mon avis d d années environ 2 99 2000 où
on a commencé à connaître nouvelle phase
nouvelle vague de l'antisémitisme qui
était peut-être plus lié à mon avis au
conflit israélo-palestinien et
l'importation voilà on a finalement eu
un renouveau de 7
déjà de cette figure du juif dans la
cité qui a un petit peu changé qui s'est
de nouveau identifié comme quelqu'un ne
faisant plus vraiment complètement
partie de la communauté nationale et
finalement petit à petit est ce que nos
politiques n'ont pas été ici là encore
je le précise l'arsenal législatif est
complet l'arsenal de textes
internationaux où la france fait partie
de toutes les associations possibles sur
la tolérance et les discours e
n'incitant pas à la haine
mais c'est là qu'on voit la limite c'est
assez proche de ce qu'on disait tout à
l'heure avec le terrorisme on voit la
limite du droit et finalement celle que
doit aussi apporter la politique dans
une forme de d'apprendre à vivre
ensemble je suis d'accord avec toi ça
passe par l'école mais ça passe aussi
par un discours public c'est à dire tout
simplement peut-être plus de fermeté
alors pas sur les actes une fois commis
mais sur la manière d'apprendre à ne
alors soit accepter des communautés qui
vivent ensemble dans une diversité par
quartier par communauté un petit peu
comme on le ferait à l'américaine à
l'anglo saxonne ou alors un véritable
vivre ensemble en se fondant dans une
masse du peuple français voilà dans ce
même article
l'une des solutions des faibles et il
sait que les joueurs se regroupent dans
le quartier qui leur ferait appeler ça
des ghettos c'est le dégager témoigne
d'une une peur on peut comprendre mais
je pense que les gars il ya des départs
on israel qui est susceptible oui oui
pour sa lutte en sécurité en israël
qu'en france comme ça c'est la classe
politique à tient un discours très juste
en disant que quand on porte atteinte à
une personne du fait de sa religion
c'est aux valeurs de la communauté
nationale de commissions auxquelles on
parle donc ces histoires de l'oeil
y'a pas de communes il ya une communauté
juive une communauté religieuse de fait
mais fondamentalement c'est toujours la
même chose en france y'a qu'une
communauté c'est la communauté nationale
et donc ça d'ailleurs plus intégrées
historiquement fin alors évidemment il
ya enfin ce nouvel anti sémite rennes
pour les accusations les désigne comme
ville exactement j'attendais ces noms
des théories de ça je lisais un papier
qui disait au fond pour résumer il ya
cet antisémitisme historique au
traditionnel en france l'antisémitisme
de la littérature de la sphère de
référence etc
mais là c'est plutôt l'antisémitisme des
chaînes d'information en continu et
d'une voix là d'une jeunesse qui se
laisse radicaliser enfin on en parlait
tout à l'heure mais il faut surtout pas
que cesser ces faits qui sont
complètement intolérables conduisent les
citoyens français de religion juive à
s'isoler entre eux à ceux à se refermer
entre je pense pas que ce soit que ce
soit ça peut être une tentation cette
tentation elle elle peut être
compréhensible mais mais c'est à la
communauté nationale de réagir c'est pas
la communauté juive
c'est de ces comportements aux valeurs
de la communauté de l'asean
je suis tout à fait d'accord avec le
fait que l'on sent citons si on veut
rester dans
dans ce qui correspond aux valeurs
françaises il faudrait arrêter de se
battre contre l'antisémitisme
l'islamophobie ou le discours anti gay
etc
mais rappelez tout simplement que comme
tu le dis la france est avant tout vivre
ensemble et que donc il faut trouver des
solutions il faut trouver des soldes
encore x encore faut-il donner les
moyens aux troupes pour ensemble un mot
quand même sur le sur le crif qui acquit
aux propos de la marche blanche a fait
savoir jean luc mélenchon et marine le
pen qui n'étaient pas les bienvenus au
thorax était de circonstance
bah oui parce que c'est un peu trop
facile pour les hommes politiques quels
qu'ils soient de passer onze mois et
demi à tenir une position et puis quand
tout d'un coup ça devient dramatique il
ya un espèce de blanchiment on y va en
détient il ya une marche blanche on va y
aller et comme ça on sera absout de tout
de tout nos bêtises et toutes nos
déclarations et je peux tout à fait
comprendre que le le conseil
représentatif des institutions juives et
pas envie de servir d'appareil de tout
comme semblait le dire mais pour une
fois qu'ils y étaient là et qui est bine
bine et c'était pas bien ben non moi je
trouve que si vraiment ils ont changé
d'avis qu'ils passent toute l'année qui
vient a montré qu'ils ont changé d'avis
et puis la prochaine marche blanche
parce que hélas on peut craindre un aura
une mignonne aura une nouvelle à ce
moment là ils viendront parce qu'ils
seront pas là pour se laver de leurs de
leurs déclarations malsaine mais ils
sont là parce qu'ils ont prouvé que
effectivement ils sont tout à fait en
phase avec les valeurs défendues par la
place n'était pas un moment de réunion
plutôt comment d'exclusion je trouve que
l'on peut parler de récupération
politique finalement quelle que soit
l'action qu'ils aient fait c'est à dire
que il ya une récupération politique
s'ils viennent puisque du coup on a le
sentiment qu'ils s'approprient
finalement ce discours de marche blanche
pour en faire un discours politique et 6
le pain ça revient un petit peu au même
puisque du coup ça veut dire que l'union
nationale n'a pas pris le pas sur les
tensions politiques donc c'est très
délicat de savoir quoi faire
je trouve que l'attitude de jean luc
mélenchon a été assez digne je sais vous
en avait déjà parlé sur ce plateau dont
je ne me prendrai nino pour me le contre
de cette question mais savoir à mon avis
d'être un petit peu plus en retrait
d'avoir notamment accepté que bon il ya
eu un moment où quand on a vu les
extraits en retrait sur le terrorisme
d'ailleurs il a été très en retrait là
dessus avec des discours à chaque fois
en tout cas le discours en hommage
dindar nobel tram à l'assemblée
nationale a été vraiment un discours où
là on parlait du sens de l'opposition il
a dit nous vous devons opposition mais
on a confiance finalement dans le dans
la nuit que vous allez mener
il fallait aussi un petit peu faire
oublier les will clarations scandaleuse
de son ex candidat qu'il était un peu
obligée il pouvait pas faire moins
ces criminels mais il est là bien sûr il
a très bien fait mais ne peut pas ne pas
le temps mais on ne peut pas le
soupçonner d'avoir la même idée que le
tweet un peu débile mais lorsque ça je
trouve ça curieux dans le dans la presse
c'est à dire que là on sépare et je suis
premier à le faire c'est pas parce que
ce sinistre individu a dit des conneries
que mélenchon en est responsable
mais quand c'est dans un autre parti
politique là on est toujours en train de
dire à ben alors lui il a fait partie de
telles parties donc tout le parti un
parti de crapule donc soirée en
grandvaux qui soit on s'arrête
et quand on comprends et je vais pas
prendre la défense du front national
mais quand un abruti du front national
déclare à propos racistes là c'est tout
de suite à wii pilote uation ses copains
de marine le pen et tout le parti n'a
surtout le touch nationale et dans le
même panier by aviation s'est classée
noire joue tout le temps dans cette
marche qui a eu lieu il y avait il y
avait en effet des gens qui étaient dans
le dos le dans cette manifestation qui
reprochait à marine le pen
les propos sur le détail auquel n'a
maintenu qu'ils sont en hausse au dessus
c'est vrai que ces voix là mais bien
évidemment je ne sais pas les meilleurs
à mélenchon des propos de son ex
candidat mais à ce moment là nous tenons
pas rigueur à tous les autres qu'ils
soient socialistes républicains ou ou
même du front national des propos d'un
militant égarés et abrutis verts qu'ils
engagent que lui voilà je suis d'accord
avec toi et je pense que justement on
peut terminer ce débat par les propos du
fils de mireille knoll qui a dit
finalement c'est bien triste de voir
comment se termine cette marche blanche
en se rendant compte qu'on a des abrutis
par tous quelle que soit la confession
religieuse quelle que soit l'extrême
droite gauche milieu que voilà vous
conseillez l'exclusion n'est jamais une
bonne conseillère
alors on va peut-être parler de nicolas
sarkozy quand même un premier sarkozy
renvoyé en correctionnelle pour
corruption et trafic d'influencé dans la
sphère des écoutes mises en examen dans
la sphère du financement par la libye de
sa campagne électorale
victime d'un acharnement des juges ou
oui bof
oui enfin non mais enfin tout en tout
cas là la justice le suivraient
la justice suit son cours après toujours
ma connaissance présumé innocent voilà
donc attendons de voir sur un point de
vue mais là nos deux professeurs de
droit vont sûrement avoir un avis très
éclairé moi ça me choque quand même
cette mise en examen elle repose quand
même sur la mise en écoute la mise sur
écoute d'un avocat que se trouve sur un
principe totalement séquencé de renvoi
en correctionnelle voilà extrêmement ce
qu il yad ailleurs les avocats sont en
recul mobiliser contre que cette
procédure repose sur un truc absolument
honteux gay quand même et qui maintenant
est enfin et pose des problèmes sans
arrêt faut plus discuté avec un avocat
au téléphone jeudi rachat grec s'adresse
à vous sacraliser la visiblement ça ne
l'est pas mais là comme si sarkozy ça
n'a l'air c'est la plus l'air de choquer
personne mais mise à part les avocats
fumée on voit plein de gens après bon
sur le fonde sur le fond de l'histoire
bâton dont la justice tranchera il a de
bons avocats il a de bons arguments
voilà deux arguments sont faux et non
mais
tu peux être un mot sur justement cette
place de la justice dans les affaires
politiques en règle générale on a parlé
de la sphère permanent
on a parlé de la ferraille roues on a
parlé fillon d'autres filles ont
évidemment qui a le sentiment qu'une
grande
il ya un laps de temps un film qui se
passe entre prenant la sphère fillon
entre la mise en cause de quelqu'un et
puis et les suites judiciaires
éventuelles qui peuvent être contre la
personne aux questions qui peuvent être
en sa faveur
et ça change quand même beaucoup les
choses
et faire fillon s'était c'est quand même
un csa comme cela quand même peut-être
coûté c'est vrai qu'il ya rien il ya
ceci je crois ce temps judiciaire il
avoue un problème 20 par rapport au
temps médiatique ou même temps au temps
politique finalement c'est ça c'est ça
la c'est ça la question c'est que je
crois que la la la la justice perd en
légitimité ce une légitimité qu'elle a
pourtant puisque comme tu dis à mon avis
sur le fond je pense que le dossier est
loin d'être vide et qu'il y aura une
solution des choses illicites étaient
présents ou futurs d'accord c'est pas le
temps judiciaire qui est en cause c'est
vraiment le temps médiatique que la
justice prenne son temps pour statuer
avec le recul nécessaire se trouve ça
très bien ce serait terrible et justice
expéditive qui s'occuperait des tournois
là on vous reproche à votre avocat le
cas que vous êtes jugé c'est fini en
trois mois ça ce serait le temps
médiatique ce serait dramatique c'est
très bien que la justice mais c'est un
peu ce qu'on a reproché parquet
financier pendant l' affaire sion c'est
à dire que voilà alors
peut-être qu'il y aura lieu absolument
c'est le temps médiatique et l'attitude
des médias et c'est un problème quand
même parce que si c'est terrible c'est
bien parce que là il à l'exploitation
pas la solution si ce n'est être
franchement de respecter la justice et
le droit
peut-être que la justice s'en mêle
devrait apprendre je trouve ça se
développe un petit peu les communiqués
de presse etc auprès des deux nous ayons
grand juge mais à prendre peut-être à
communiquer un petit peu mieux sur le
temps qui est nécessaire aussi bien pour
une instruction qu une mise en examen
etc
on a beaucoup discuté savoir si la garde
à vue de la sarkozie était nécessaire ou
pas la raison certains disent c'était
humiliant et vêtements aux millions
parce que c'est pas quelqu'un qui allait
partir de janvier un des deux juges avec
a convoqué on sentait tout une
humiliation ridicule sa mission n'avait
si les juges l'avaient simplement
convoqué on aurait dit un traitement
très fier citoyen qui veut être comme
tous les autres mais là j'avoue que la
discussion est ouverte j'ai pas de c'est
toujours difficile d'arriver à lui passé
chez son épouse oui mais quand même la
moindre des choses
enfin il est dans mes gardes à vue et
les lieux quand est ce qu'elle est ce
qu'elle a un caractère de
de faire en sorte que quelqu'un qui est
qui va peut-être être mis en examen ne
s'enfuit pas un caractère comme ça on
sait juste la garde à vue
oui nous la garde à vue c'est une mesure
de d'interrogation un petit peu sur
pouces et voilà c'est le temps c'est un
acte d' enquête qui signifie pas
nécessairement que alors on a tous ces
films en tête où on a le sentiment que
du coup l'aller les forces de police
vont ont martyrisé quelqu'un pendant
plus de 24 heures en réalité n'obtenant
il ya un avocat il y avait la présence
[Musique]
des choses donc c'est une mesure de
denquête choisi minots de la sphère
strauss kahn avec ses walthéry bref
voilà on n'est pas à l'amérique
qu'est ce qui vous lie risque pas de
s'enfuir non plus les caméras du monde
entier étaient braqués sur lui et
pourtant il a connu rikers island à
après pour emmener un seul ce que nous
disions précédemment ce qui serait
important aussi tout le respect que je
dois à que je porte à la justice et que
on pourrait peut-être rappeler quand
même à certains juste que l'instruction
ses secrets et qu' il est parfois
curieux et c'est pas toujours leur les
avocats quand même quelquefois des
fuites des choses qui sont pas très
normal qui n'est que la cerise et une
même scène flingue mediapart l'a en fait
au courant de la garde à vue alors
commencer et ça il ya probable a
probablement deux quelque chose à faire
c'est un secret sans limiter le droit
d'un qui que ce soit mais simplement en
rappelant certaines règles une certaine
déontologie entre guillemets à certains
certains acteurs de la justice notamment
parce que la justice se plaint ensuite
de l'intrusion des médias donc le secret
de l'instruction est mise à mal aussi
bien dans la sphère d'aval que dans la
sphère fillon on a vu des choses fuite
et qui sont dans les journaux avant que
les juges puissent même d'en avoir
connaissance et je trouve ça dramatique
c'est vrai qu'il faut arriver à bien
séparer les deux sphères pour que les
deux gardent leur légitimité je crois
que c'est vrai qu'il ya quand même un
certain nombre de gens qui doit renoncer
au président de république
alors je sais bien que ça peut choquer
les jeunes est louable mais on devrait
le laisser tranquille quoi c'est quand
même la république on attaque à travers
lui c'est quand même la fonction qu'on a
tâté traverse à monsieur je ne suis pas
du tout pour qu'on le laisse tranquille
eu un maillage ya maintenant je trouve
ça tout à fait normal en revanche
d'accord avec vous on vous dit
il faut le traiter comme les autres il
n'y a pas cinquante mille ex président
de la république effectivement une
fonction il a été élu et c'est donc on
aurait pu concevoir qu'on est con lui
évite cette garde à vue qui n'a
véritablement servi à rien parce qu'il
se serait pas dérobé la convocation du
juge experts donc voilà il ya nous reste
3 3 président de la république qu'à
président de la république combiné voilà
éventuellement est invoquée en justice
voilà c'est pas le plus violent c'est
pas le tout venant medal of sa porte
oui ça ça porte atteinte notamment les
trous j'étais terreur et puis aux yeux
des citoyens à la république est le même
mais réaliser aussi la situation inverse
dans laquelle on aurait pu se trouver
c'est-à-dire anduze emballé chers amis
monsieur le président on oublie tout on
rase gratis là dans ce cas là la
république et vous rêviez j'ai été
extrêmement hâte a fait bâtir a été
condamné
ça laisse à président correctionnelle
est mis en examen
c'est hollande pour l'instant rien sur
les endroits ça et ça me rend fier
d'être français parce que je trouve ça
absolument extraordinaire que dans un
pays qu'on critique à longueur de
journée on est quand même il n'y a pas
tant de démocratie que ça où on peut
mettre effectivement un ancien président
de république en garde à vue déféré ça
se passe et herman en correctionnelle le
en condamner un autre pan d'un premier
ministre et que ça il ya quand même une
une véritable un véritable preuve de
démocratie que l'étape des textes
racistes
on a une belle philosophie c'est que
justement on est à la fois protecteur de
ce statut de président de la république
notamment pendant le monde pendant le
programme c'est ça qui est intéressant
c'est que on distingue l'homme du mandat
et il est finalement intéressant aussi
que la justice ne soit pas à deux
vitesses et qu'on recouvre une égalité
quand le prix venant des plus des plus
consciente qu'il redevient un millier
d'hommes un mot puisque universitaire
que vous êtes sur ce qui se passe à
montpellier les violences à l'université
de montpellier ou de vriendt la fac de
droit
ses fonctions que vous avez exercé a été
obligé de démissionner afin vous n'avez
jamais été obligé de démissionner et je
n'ai pas les nationales et jusqu'au bout
de mes cinq années de mandat
oui alors il ya un autre enseignant qui
avoue avoir
frappé de la violence dont un collègue
dont masquer ainsi voire présume
alors tout ça vient de la réforme de
l'entrée dans l'enseignement supérieur
un parcours sup en effet pas tout à fait
alors c'est vrai qu'on était assez
mécontents d'apb sur plein de peu sur
plein de points qui est l algorithme qui
fonctionnait auparavant et qui vont
comme toute intelligence artificielle
est une intelligence qui reste
artificiel mais aujourd'hui parcours su
que je trouve que c'est encore un peu
tôt alors bon les mouvements étudiants
on sait qu'ils s'auto pour des idiots
voilà ce sont des étudiants qui sont
déjà en fait qu'ils sont en train de se
plaindre d'un système d'entrée en fac
dont on ne connaît pas encore forcément
les résultats
mais voilà bon de là on arrivait à la
situation qui a été celle de montpellier
évidemment je crois qu'en tant
qu'enseignant on peut dire qu'on ne
partage pas du tout les évolutions de la
situation dans ces unions ont laissé
faire
sinon sinon facilité je ne sais pas on
verra bien vert bien les enquêtes mais
en tout cas le pour l'interview de notre
collègue doyen de la fac de montpellier
et fat intéresse est un naufrage
naufrage en termes de communication suis
pas expert lanfains voilà et sur le fond
mais unissant qu'il était fier enfin
évidemment
possible est intervenue mais oui mais
au-delà de cela j'ai vraiment à coeur si
vous voulez cesser ces valeurs
universitaires enfin c'est c'est
essentiellement pour cela que je fais ce
métier qui sont des valeurs de 2,2 de
liberté de rigueur de débat restait de
respect ce qui veut pas dire que tout
les lénifiants à l'université au bien au
contraire le débat et y est parfois très
vifs et que c'est sans doute l'un encore
l'un des derniers lieux de la société
dans lesquels on peut avoir des débats
vifs mais relativement respectueuse
pascale audret relativement respectueux
de l'autre et donc c'est bien sûr de
toujours sur le fond j'en veux
sur le fond il ya 20 ans le mot le mot
est très fort mais je l'avais déjà dit à
des étudiants qui avaient empêché un
débat de se tenir à des étudiants d'un
parti politique qui avaient envahi un
amphithéâtre dans lequel je me trouvais
il ya presque pour moi un caractère
sacré des lieux universitaires ça et on
parlait c'est plus un fantasme qu'autre
chose d'ailleurs c'est pas du droit des
franchises universitaires et les forces
de l'ordre ne peuvent pas entrer dans
les locaux universitaires comme elles ne
peuvent pas entrer dans un édifice du
culte etc qui a braqué mai 68 dont
certaines notamment provoqué mais bon
ces franchises doivent être très conçu
de manière très très distanciée parce
qu'au fond oui les forces de l'ordre
peuvent intervenir bon mais il ya une
tradition qui existe depuis le moyen-âge
et donc il ya pour moi presque oui un
caractère sacré des amphithéâtres et
donc ce caractère sacré il est en
quelque sorte profané temps parce qu'ils
empêchent la tenue des enseignements que
par a fortiori les collègues des
collègues qui vous chic à aller frapper
des étudiants fin c'est complètement
incroyable et de surcroît un l'un des
deux collègues qui assume parfaitement
qu'il ne l'a vraiment basque et qui est
aujourd'hui
suspendu et qui est objet je crois d'une
mise en examen enfin voila c c'est
surréaliste
il s'est passé aussi des incidences sont
déroulés à devant la fac de droit de
lille mais c'était à l'extérieur donc
les il n'y a rien ici bas et coûter
jusqu'à preuve du contraire tout va bien
non nous nous travaillons et saveurs et
c'est sur ces paroles de sagesse que
vous proposez nous quitter merci merci
infiniment de charme bezina merci
c'était de bon sens merci ton chaleureux
10 et à très vite pour un nouveau
d'humour de paf
[Musique]
communiquer tout ça c'était chiant